Speaker 1: And that actually brings us to
another story here.
In the United States, not just Florida anymore,
we're talking about the entire country, the
number of children being hospitalized for
covid has hit a new record.
And what's really disturbing, too, is that
even though we have a record number of children
hospitalized, recovered, they still only make
up two point four percent of covid hospitalizations.
So more kids than ever, but because we also
have more people than ever.
This is what we have stories out on Sunday
telling us that over in Texas, I believe it
was, they're doing what New York had to do
in the early days of the pandemic, and they're
setting up hospital beds in the parking garage.
It was either Texas or Mississippi, I forget.
Oh, but Mississippi actually did have an eighth
grader die of covid.
An eighth grader, 13, 14 years old, eligible
for the vaccine, but had not received it,
as far as we know.
Died from covid.
Because there was no safe way to send all
these kids back to school.
And for the record, yes, under 18, hospitalizations
are at a record high.
You know what else is going up?
The 19 through 29, the thirty through thirty
nine, the forty three, forty nine in every
age group, the number of covid hospitalizations
is approaching an all time high.
And unfortunately, this Delta variant does
seem to be far more disastrous for younger
people, even for healthy people without any
comorbidities, then original covid.
The disease is getting worse.
The virus is getting worse, it's continuing
to mutate, and it's affecting people that
a year ago, if they got covid, well, wasn't
a big deal or they may have even been asymptomatic
from it.
That's no longer the case, remember, I mean,
remember that last summer they said, well,
you know, this is a disease of the elderly
or the obese or people with a lot of comorbidities.
Not anymore.
We are seeing formerly healthy people die
of this, we are seeing people come out of
this that may have permanent lung problems
as a result of this disease.
And Republican leaders continue to whistle
past the graveyard, digging in their heels
and saying, no, we're not going to change
what we've already done because, oh, well,
then it might make us look foolish.
Protect your citizens, I promise you, you're
going to get rewarded politically more for
helping your residence than you will for letting
them die.
I don't know why it's so hard for these Republican
leaders to get that through their brains,
but that's the situation we're dealing with
now.
You can either piss off the minority of people
who are anti mask and anti vax or you can
kill off enough of your base to where you'll
never win an election again.
Seems like a pretty simple equation to me,
I'm Ferrin, cousins of four David Pakman.
We'll be right back.